is working from home morally wrong no no
it's not the world's changed the
economy's changed the ethics of work
have changed we went through an
extraordinary period during the pandemic
uh the idea that you split up a
headquarters and you let people leave a
headquarters and work from home was was
you know not even contemplated was
considered too risky now it's a proven
effective method of project management
in elon's case it you know to be fair
about what he's talking about when you
are in a highly engineered business like
Tesla's or SpaceX I get the idea that
you want collaboration between Engineers
that are sitting around trying to solve
design problems or whatever but it has
nothing to do with the other 10 sectors
of the economy if you have employees you
need to check out the ERC program Chef
wonderful why Mr Wonderful because it's
cash flow that you don't have to pay
back good to know this guy's so smart
and so handsome
go to wondertrust.com